almost 5 million children have been
diagnosed with covid since the pandemic
began cases and hospitalizations are
increasing significantly in kids as a
delta variant surges now the american
academy of pediatrics is encouraging
parents to get eligible children
protected anthony perra reports
the alegrias are always on the go with
14 year old greg and 13 year old liam in
sports and other activities the teens
got the covet vaccine the first day they
were eligible my parents were in their
80s and we wanted to spend time with
them my one son was going to camp for a
month and my other son was going on a
backpacking trip and they both wanted to
be able to go do those things with with
confidence i want to do a vaccine uh so
i um life could be more normal i guess
are we there yet the american academy of
pediatrics is launching a campaign
urging parents to vaccinate their
children and encouraging them to talk to
their pediatrician about concerns in
adolescence ages 12 and up in the trials
it showed 100 percent efficacy so i
think parents should feel really
reassured that the vaccine will help
keep their children healthy it'll help
keep them well the delta variant is
spreading among the unvaccinated
including kids nearly 204 thousand
tested positive in one week levels not
seen since winter children now account
for 22 percent of cases
children are less likely to get severe
illness but they can still get very very
ill the risks of getting coveted are
significantly greater than the risks of
the vaccine to date 9.3 million children
are fully vaccinated about 46 percent of
16 and 17 year olds and 37 percent of 12
to 15 year olds it doesn't hurt at all
either my kids have been getting
vaccines since they were babies i put my
faith in the doctors then and
i i don't know why anyone won it now
this mom is grateful they're protected
and doing their part to protect others
anthony perra cbs news
the vaccine is not available yet to
children under 12 years old data on the
safety and effectiveness of the vaccine
in children 5 to 11 is expected later
this month